chaque soir à 19h pile un tonnerre
d'applaudissements surgi du centre ville
de vancouver
les vancouvérois sorte par milliers sur
leur balcon pour rendre un hommage aux
héros méconnus de cette guerre contre la
copie 19 il travailleurs de première
ligne comme l'infirmier jérémy siffert
qui se lève aux petites heures du matin
pour se rendre à l'urgence de l'hôpital
général de vancouver les urgences de la
province ont deux fois moins de
visiteurs que d'habitude car les gens
restent à la maison
mais c'est le calme avant la tempête
donc on se prépare pour une arrivée
massive qui pas encore arrivé mais on se
prépare chaque jour en discret mais qu
on est tous dans la même situation ont
vraiment on y aura du stress ordinaire
travailleurs en arrivant jérémy doit
méticuleusement revêtir des vêtements
protecteurs des gants un masque et même
des lunettes de sécurité ce qui n'était
pas nécessairement qu'à l'urgence
auparavant le risque est omniprésent en
italie soixante neuf médecins sont morts
après avoir attrapé lakovic 19 pendant
longtemps ça c'est stressant parce qu'on
se dit ça peut m'arriver à moi demain ou
à mes collègues mes amis ça mais la
différence si vous n'avez plus de temps
se préparer que en italie par exemple
l'hôpital général de vancouver a été
reconfigurée pour s'adapter à la
pandémie
certaines unités ont été temporairement
réaffecter afin d'augmenter le nombre de
lits disponibles pour les patients aux
soins intensifs ya un ennemi qu'est le
coc u19 et là on en train d'être
entraînée pour se préparer à cet ennemi
là donc nous aussi on est comme des
soldats qui qui se prépareront à cette
attaque fait pour l'instant la colombie
britannique ne prévoit pas de pénurie de
masques ou de respirateurs même selon
les scénarios les plus pessimistes
plus de 400 infirmiers et infirmières à
la retraite se sont portés volontaires
pour venir prêter main forte aux besoins
on fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
maintenance et à la population de faire
leur partie du job qui est resté à la
maison
lorsque le quart de travail du personnel
hospitalier prend fin vers 19 heures un
cortège de voitures de police défilent
devant l'hôpital les policiers et les
pompiers ou s'ils manifestent leur
soutien aux travailleurs de la santé ces
gens prennent d'énormes risques pour les
canadiens et ils méritent d'être
appréciées 17 vancouvéroise qui a lancé
l'idée des applaudissements il y a deux
semaines
un effort qui amène du réconfort à ceux
qui doivent monter au front l'autre jour
j'avais une journée de repos et j'ai
entendu les gens applaudir et veille
près des casseroles et tape dessus écrit
dit merci et j'avoue que ça m'a fait un
peu d'émotion parce que on a vraiment du
stress à aller aller au travail
c'est vrai que c'est important de sentir
que la population nous oublie pas et qu'
ils réalisent tout ce qu'on fait ici
frédéric zajac radio canada vancouver
[Applaudissements]